do you want me to take it out
i took a class in systems design and
engineering and in this class we
designed
this system intended to be a prototype
energy storage system for a grima 600
unmanned underwater vehicle
lincoln lab
wanted us to extend the operating time
the rhema 600 currently is able to
operate for approximately three days on
lithium ion batteries
gasoline has an amazing energy density
which is several times more than
batteries
the test that we're gonna run is going
to consist of having the vehicle surface
run the engine and then dive
all right
let's start that engine up then
based on a command that the vehicle
receives it can start the engine
run the engine
and then shut down successfully
uh tell the vehicle to seal off all the
valves for the snorkel and for the water
intake
and then allow it to fill with water
into a plenum and that allows the
vehicle to have enough neutral buoyancy
that it can submerge
it's been a bit stressful getting it in
there
it's a complex system and a lot of
things can happen so you gotta have a
flight checklist to go through
that has
two end tanks each one of these tanks
has a fuel bladder and a water bladder
inside
as it uses up fuel it replaces the fuel
with an equal mass of water and air to
make sure the entire system stays at
constant mass and therefore constant
buoyancy
the engine right here turns a generator
which then produces electricity
that can be sent to an auxiliary battery
pack that the rest of the system can use
this here is the exhaust we actually
have check valve so we don't get back
flow
into the engine exhaust because we don't
want to have sea water shooting up back
into our engine exhaust
in here is the brains of the system it
is pick microcontroller
there's a whole variety of
valves pumps
and sensors that are used to make sure
the system is maintained within its
operable bounds
it is a proof of concept